est ce que vous voulez pas nous faire
une petite danse américaine
[Applaudissements]
le tacle est un questionnement je peux
tenir le micro pas là pour ça
on cherche la musique sont en train de
chercher musique américaine époux n'ont
pas ce que tu veux quand même pas porté
une piscine plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi vous allez mais attention
cette semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quantifier
quand ça
[Applaudissements]
on ne savait pas trop si
jamais le lundi comme je dors avec elle
en fin de semaine
merci gâteries américaine américaine
mais franchement art déco nommé parce
que je connais je connais que ouais quoi
je connaissais pas les sondages ça fait
rêver elle est très jeune mais c'est
incroyable
c'est pas que ça donne de l'espoir oui
et elle avait des enfants elle a eu des
enfants franchement c'est vraiment moi
c'est fou voulait faire une bande ou oui
[Applaudissements]
et je te
ramène nous dit-on petit navire
allez
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien fait de venir
à bord
j'y vais pas
voilà ben voilà c'est vraiment une
petite frappe
jamais lundi je vous met en lumière
j'étais juste comme ça va bien sûr pas
lundi ce jour
chadha week end voilà voilà qu'est ce
qui s'est passé rachid gt gt par monts
et par vaux ah oui donc forcément je
suis pas dans la danse la condamnation
détient aux loges avec mon ami l'a juste
avant
et et il ya une scène incroyable fou je
raconte
je m'en fous ça raconte guillaume genton
m'a fait la meilleure vannes de la
journée on était créatrice a dans la
loge avec guillaume et guillaume fait
une interview de béatrice un carton et
où en ce moment avec ton mec ça se passe
avec le maroc au sahara view fleuve
il filme interview - 24 y soit ou pas
tant avec ton mari et cetera et cetera
ella ella jeudi à guillaume g et ab1
c'est un bond au sein du bel20 béatrice
il a fait ses comptes en temps
[Rires]
étant de la crise ionique ça allait très
bien avec son mari celle à qui
aujourd'hui ont choisi de se refaire les
ongles
célina non mais c'est vrai il a fait une
interview l'été sur le canapé ou laurent
boyer frère c'est comme ça qu'on est en
train de faire une interview et s'est
livré sur armand ouais c'est vrai nom
mais ça ils
sont fous de béatrice parce que raymond
et foot béatrice qu'il n'en parlons pas
des malheurs des jours une maman j
jean-michel jean-michel je pense qu'il
est en apoplexie bien sûr mais c'est
vrai qu'à chaque ville a toujours pas vu
[Applaudissements]